hi everybody so thanks for coming I'm
gonna take these post-it notes that we
gathered and kind of do a a grouping
here and I'm gonna ask a few questions
as we go but this only take a second we
have a few more thank you well look at
that all right
I'll put that one there this is fun for
me but it's also got a purpose not sure
where that one goes okay if you can't
read this I apologize but I'm gonna try
to I'll read them off we have a grouping
that's rather common is so interesting
okay well variety hey everybody so this
talk is about estimates and no estimates
we'll come back to this in a moment
no estimates with a question mark but I
want to start out just coming up with a
common definition of what we're talking
about now everybody's way up above me
here I can't see everybody very well but
we'll have another participatory part to
this and when we do that I'll have you
we'll figure out how we're going to do
that so I'm going to talk to you about
first of all the hashtag of no estimates
that's just sort of a consequence of
talking about no estimates if you do it
in Twitter you end up eventually with a
hashtag on it so I want to talk about a
little bit and then come up to a couple
definitions of things so we have a
common understanding so first of all the
hashtag I first started using this in
2012 and I believe I was the first one
at least in this conversation to use the
hashtag of no estimates but what I was
intending because this came from earlier
talks that I had given was to I was
talking about the sorts of things that
people are reluctant to talk about that
I think we should be talking about when
we're doing software development and so
basically these are the status quo sort
of items the things that
we just do because that's what we do and
I believe it's in those areas that we
hide a lot of our problems because we're
no longer willing to discuss these
things maybe it's too hard to discuss
them may we're not allowed to discuss
them but one example that was estimates
and as I start talking about these sorts
of things and talking about estimates it
really turned out that there was a lot
of reluctance to talk about it but once
you got talking about it there was also
a lot of what I would say difficulty in
having a calm discussion so I thought we
should be able to have a calm discussion
about it so that's basically what the
hashtag was for I started using it in
2012 I didn't invent this hashtag to be
controversial I used it to show to use
as a marker for this bigger discussion
and I was I'd written a little article
for someone else that had been
discussing this with about a project I
worked on where we did not use estimates
and they wanted to know how did that
work how did that go so I wrote this
article about it and it really actually
turned out that that got a lot of
attention and so it started building the
conversation that I was really looking
for I wanted to find people who were
interested in talking with me about
problems they had seen with estimates
and how they had dealt with it so that
was basically you know what was
interesting to me and this was a
mechanism for getting that I'm gonna
plug in my clicker thing here and see if
that works okay so the thing is the
controversy came for free this was not
what I intended it just was something
that had happened so let's go from there
I like to share this concept right here
I learned this about 20 or 30 years ago
maybe actually 35 years ago from a
gentleman who I wanted to learn some
stuff from and I tracked him down and I
said you know I got this stuff I want to
learn from you and he said yeah I'd be
happy to show you however that's
important stuff but there's something
that's a lot more important and he
shared this quote from an artist with me
from about a hundred years ago and I I
took this to heart basically if we use
this for software to
element this we could read as the object
isn't to create great software it's to
be in that wonderful state where great
software is inevitable and I like to
think of it a little bit more expanded
and that is to think that this isn't
about creating software as such it's
about creating the environment in which
software will just happen and the right
stuff will happen I want everybody to
excel in their life and to excel in
their work and when we do that we create
that environment we're gonna get better
stuff done we're gonna get the right
things done so what happened for me is
this kind of game became a guiding light
and that's what I'm sharing here over
all that is that if we can make an
environment where it's safe for us to
talk about things like are the estimates
helping us that's going to help us
overall already so we have to narrow
down the conversation because otherwise
this goes into too much to talk about so
if I narrow down the conversation to a
specific use of estimates and that's all
I want to talk about for the moment then
we can have a sane conversation and I'm
gonna give you a little bit of that so
first I want to start with this this is
about I'm asking what is an estimate
what in what is the essence of what an
estimate is I've grouped them over here
as the things that come to me close to
guests so here's one that says a wild
guess
here's somebody who said wrong an
estimate is wrong I think that that kind
of is a comment that's saying regardless
have how we do it it's still not very
helpful to us and I'm gonna kind of
group that and guess is that okay -
pudding guess so everybody think that's
okay
okay so here's one that says a guess
here's one that says guess here's one
that says it's a number and I would take
that to mean it's sort of a meaningless
number is that okay to call that a guess
tell me no or yes yes okay I don't want
to force you to think the same way I do
what I want to do is come to a common
understanding we can move that out if we
want to a glance into a crystal ball I'm
gonna put that under guess is that okay
a guess guess automatically goes under
guess guess work
a guess I guess I guess I want to get
every one of these up there a lottery
that's almost worse than a guess but I'm
gonna put that over there right and this
last one here is a prediction is it okay
to call a prediction a guess I'm gonna
call that a guess we may have different
beliefs about that oh here's one that
says a wish so that's kind of saying
well I hope it's gonna be like this so
I'm gonna put that under guess if that's
all right with you all righty now here's
some other kinds of words
it's breakable it's difficult it's an
expectation so is it really so I'm gonna
move this over I think to there it's
getting an idea of how long something
will take it doesn't really give you an
idea of how long something will take or
is it a guess about how long something
will take nobody's willing to you're
afraid of what I'll do to you if you say
it wrong let's let's just we'll leave
that over here it's an interval I'm not
sure how to rate that one so I'll just
gonna put that here here we have time a
measurement I'm not sure an estimate is
a measurement but maybe it's an estimate
of a measurement it's a its resources
its cost so I could say it this way an
estimate is a guess about the time or
the resources of the cost does that make
sense and over here we have a deadline
an expectation or an expectation so a
guess a an estimate is a guess about the
time cost effort whatever so we can set
a deadline that's the beginnings of what
I usually find so when I do this I've
did this several times I'm going to skip
to ahead this is one where I had a group
of about a hundred people who responded
this pile over here is Ida Kate use my
arrow here doesn't work very good about
25 of those stickies say guess or
something close enough that the group
accepted as guests and then we've got
time cost
work so we're making it's the same thing
you came up with here I've done this
exercise something like 200 times now
and I get a very similar layout to this
so are we agreed that an estimate is a
guess about time or cost so we can do
some kind of planning is that good
enough shout it out if you if you get
sick just tell me I'm wrong if I'm wrong
tell me I'm right if I'm right all right
so I'm right enough so then I could come
up with this kind of a definition so
this is what I want to be talking about
it's approximate calculation or judgment
we can call that a guess about the time
amount of time work time hour elapsed
time we'll talk that about that next to
create a project to feature some bit of
work in developing software so that's
sort of how I want to do it when I when
we say it's a calculation or approximate
calculation or judgment I'm gonna
replace the word guess I think it's a
guess I should just change that in the
slides alrighty so let's do an estimate
you're gonna have to somebody's going to
have to shout out so I hate to put you
on the spot here it is we're gonna take
this little thing to estimate three
months from today you will need to write
your name on a white in this card with a
blue fountain pen how long will that
take to actually do the work we're not
counting the three months it's the day
you need to do the work how long is that
going to take somebody 10 seconds you'd
have to get everything first but we
could write the name in 10 seconds or is
that what we said let's stick with 10
seconds but you're kind of going down
the right path that's what we need to
ask because if I asked you so if it's 10
seconds to write our name we have
everything we need to do it what if we
needed to do it right now how long would
it take somebody venture a guess an hour
what do we need to do to be able to do
it we have to find that index card and
we have to find the pen so that's sort
of what you were asking right so the
actual work of writing the name may not
be all the work
but an hour I would say it's possible
that could be optimistic because first
of all you don't know what size of an
index card we need to write it on and
you don't know if we allow it to have
lines on it or not so that's a beginning
what about another requirement when I
say a blue fountain pen do I mean a
fountain pen with blue ink or a fountain
pen that is blue in color if you brought
it to me and it's a and it's blue ink I
go that's not what I make used to black
fountain pen then you wouldn't have met
the requirement so this is kind of the
problem with estimates of all the time
we think we understand what we need to
make the estimate of we'll get onto this
a little bit later so this I just want
to show about the actual work time which
is the time it takes to do the work if
we don't have any waiting we don't have
any we don't have anybody interrupting
us we have all the things we need to do
it and the day goes relatively well so
that might be the actual time to do it
no context switching what happens when
the boss comes in and taps you on the
shoulder and they say can I interrupt
you for a moment and what do you answer
when they do that you already have so
clearly you can so the other part of it
though is elapsed time so that's how
much time sometimes we call this cycle
time or lead time I use elapsed that's
the time from when we first start to
work til we're done with it so in the
case of the writing with a fountain pen
when we started is when we went out and
got more requirements and said he what
size of a card could have lines on it is
that a blue pen or is a blue ink or
whatever and then we go and buy the
things that we need may we order them
online and we get them now we do the
actual work which is what we thought
they were as asking us to estimate in
the first place and then we can deliver
it so that could take a while matter of
fact I've done this like I said this
exercise a several hundred times in the
audience I usually ask does anybody
actually have a fountain pen with blue
ink at an actual fountain pen does
anybody have one here this is a rare
thing anymore because we usually don't
even have pens on us you know we you
our Twitter device that's about all we
got so if we have these two different
understandings of what an instrument is
about then we really need there's some
stuff we got to figure out there's
really some stuff we got to figure out
our estimate is going to be useful for
us until we have a good definition now I
like to do this little exercise and I
think I have enough people here to do it
but I'm not gonna do it on post-it notes
what I'm gonna ask us to do is to gather
into groups of three and four if you're
sitting there people that looks like you
can actually interact with them without
getting in a fight then group up that
way if nobody wants to work with you
that's telling you something you should
pay attention to so what I want you to
do is just group into groups of three or
four quickly come up with three four or
five ideas about why do we do estimates
and then I'm going to I'm gonna put a
timer on then I'm gonna kind of ask the
audience so each group be ready with a
couple of your ideas or maybe just one
idea and then we'll go and see how many
unique ideas we can find why do you why
do we do estimates you ready to do that
talk to the people near you or you can
turn around talk to people behind you if
the people behind you are turning around
talking to the people behind them then
talk to people in front of you go ahead
and do it
you got three minutes I bet you we have
enough ideas now do we does everybody
did everybody come up with least a
couple ideas so somebody just give me
the first somebody give me that one of
the ideas why do we do estimates because
we have to because you've been asked to
do it by somebody you can't deny okay
anything different than that one well I
should ask first how many got something
like that
so that's at least twelve or fifteen
groups and we only have twenty groups
here maybe right what else do we get for
learning okay what else so time effort
tracking the tracking system we use
requires this yes so we're doing this so
we can guess whether we can do this
amount of work within this specific
amount of time okay what else to plan
resources do we plant enough corn this
year is that what we mean like did we
buy or human resources okay they tell us
nowadays don't call humans resources I
don't call them people what else
cost-benefit so a cost-benefit analysis
as to whether there's a chance this will
make money for us
two weeks to develop we'll do something
else because we won't get enough benefit
out of it right what else anything
different to set priorities should we do
this first or that first what else to
see if we have the same understanding
anything different what's that for
pricing so that's so we can give
somebody a price this software would
cost you eight million six hundred and
fifty thousand five thousand money units
and that's what we need to tell so they
can make a decision is that what we're
saying you're giving a bit so somebody
else can use that information you're
giving it to them to give them a idea of
the cost and that is one of the things
we we had there any others I have a
feeling there's probably five or six
others but their nuances let's work with
that because I think I can work with
that so software development will use
estimates to attempt to predict the
future because for example we can do the
cost analysis and determine if the
benefit is sufficient only based on our
estimates when we actually do the work
maybe nobody wants to use the software
we just wrote and we goofed up on the
value estimate but I'm not really
talking about value estimates here just
the cost side but part of it is let's
figure out the cost so we want to know
things like when will it be done how
much will it cost what can we get done
during this period of time I think all
these you brought up how many people
will we need what can we get for this
money and then of course you said over
here because we have to because
somebody's forcing us to do them and we
want to keep our job so this is sort of
what we talked about this is close to
what you gave me here but somebody else
takes a couple of you took it a little
bit further because we don't just do
these estimates and then we get that
information we're going to use the
information for something and so
basically we why do we do them we use
this information to help us make
decisions and I think this is part of
where the problems start
because we want help making decisions
but I've asked this question in many
places I very rarely hear back this we
want this information to help us make
good decisions they just want to help
make decisions I actually brought with
me a very economical decision-making
mechanism with me and if I flip this
coin I'm not sure which is heads or
tails but I could say the side with the
date and I say if the side with the date
comes up then we'll do this and if not
we won't that helped me make the
decision because maybe others were
reluctant to make the decision so we
don't just need help making the decision
we want help making a good decision so
but we heard another one too so most of
it is we want information that helps us
make the decision also to exploit the
conversation so I think a couple of you
here kind of said that this opens up the
floor to the conversation I'm going to
kind of cover that later if we have
enough time I think there are other and
perhaps better ways to have that
conversation I'm just kind of suggesting
that so I'm gonna share with you some of
my thinking so we don't have enough time
to make this a full workshop so but I
just wanted to get a little bit of this
to get information from you hopefully
we're on the same page as understanding
why do we do the estimates and what an
estimate is we're making some guesses to
help us hopefully make good decisions so
part ii there are 83 parts so we're
gonna have to rush through the rest of
them i want to talk about how it started
for me have any of you heard me tell
this before anybody here okay because i
was here a couple years ago and maybe
they've replaced all the developers they
had then with new developers i guess so
i want to tell this story because i once
this occurred for me i started noticing
something similar all over the place and
that's what started making me think we
better be talking about this so i took a
job in 1999 it was the second quarter of
1999 i just finished a contract that was
glorious the people didn't do estimates
they worked in a very extreme
programming manner of delivering
something into production
or close to production depending on what
exactly they were doing daily they would
take on some work work very closely with
the customer start delivering stuff
right away and there weren't any
estimates needed for what they were
doing I really liked everything about
what they were doing and I thought I
want more of this and so as I learned
about it was extreme programming most of
what they were doing we would recognize
now as being agile so I thought I like
this I want more of this well I couldn't
find anything like this
exactly and there was nothing called
agile then agile didn't come along until
2001 as a term as a way of thinking
about it so this was the scenario there
were they were it was a large important
project for a company with they were
hiring 200 software developers most of
them were quite young I was one of the
oldest in the group and this was almost
well 20 years ago almost and but what I
liked about it they were gonna do what's
called IID which is iterative
incremental development it's sort of
like agile the idea would be that you're
gonna do some bit of work you're gonna
get it into use you can learn something
from it but they left out to get it into
use part still they were doing these
iterations I liked it I wanted more of
that and also a big part of this is that
they were gonna do a lessons learned at
the end of each iteration it was sort of
an open-ended contract for me but they
thought this work would take three to
six months how long is a three-month
project by the way can anybody tell me
three-month project is about two years
it's very accurate thank you so this did
turn into about a two-year project I
left after six months because I didn't
want to be part of that what I would
consider nastiness of the test test and
fix cycle breaking things and fixing
them and they'd break something else and
fixing them and it went on for a long
time there okay so I liked this so here
we are the first week they grant
gathered everybody together and we
charged out to do our designing and our
basically upfront work for this
iteration we were determining how much
can we get done how long would it take
to do this thing versus that thing they
were making decisions like that and then
they designed the the modules we were
going to write and
we would go to write them and at the end
of the three week six weeks we did the
lessons learned I noticed two things
from the lessons learned meetings that
we had that really stuck out the first
one was our estimates were off they
weren't very helpful to us why did it
why did we not get as much done and why
was why was there a lot of things that
took much longer than we thought they
should take they asked how are we gonna
fix this so what would you do if your
estimates are off what is one way that
you can fix them maybe somebody can
shout that out what do you do well
multiply it by a number let's use four
but yes that let's pad it but what do we
do what can we do we can inflate them
well that's kind of the easy way they
really wanted to sincerely do something
get better at estimates that's what they
thought we need to get better at
estimates here's a bunch of young people
they really haven't had a chance to
learn how to do estimates they have to
get better at estimates so the
management firms said we'll get some
trainers in here we'll learn how to do
the estimates also the other thing I
noticed was kind of twofold we didn't
really we didn't understand the
requirements and they kept changing well
during the development period so what do
we do about that anybody want to take a
stab at it
we should plan better which kind of
means we should understand better the
requirements so there wasn't clear
requirements so let's get clearer
requirements and let's understand them
better and what else work closer with
the client what I'm looking for one
thing we often do let's cover the second
one the requirements kept changing let's
not allow them to change so that's
called change control hopefully you're
not living in that world anymore but
that's what we decide we needed to do
now I didn't decide that me being
slightly older than everyone else had
already seen these problems and I had a
suspicion they weren't actually the real
problems so we worked hard to get better
we got some study on how to do estimates
we practiced we we worked diligently to
do better estimates
and we worked hard to control the
changes and understand things better in
the first place we charged off on our
second iteration of six weeks at the end
of which we had our lessons learned I
noticed two things maybe kind of three
that we were having a problem with that
came up as being important enough for us
to try and improve what were those two
things the estimates were off and the
requirements were unclear and they kept
changing I don't need to go through it
very I can just bring them all out we
know what's happening here they decided
to do the same thing
let's get better at estimates we clearly
didn't get better last time let's
control the changes let's understand
things better we actually worked hard to
do that everybody there was very
diligent about getting better at their
craft they were trying to learn to do
what that was expected of them what they
were told to do yeah I'm glad you were
here that was a good thing to say we
charged off to do the work and at the
hour lessons learned what did we find
same thing so what do we do about this
at by this point I thought I should say
something you know there was like six or
seven of us that were about my age group
and most everybody else was half our age
and I thought being the kind of older
guy I wasn't a manager I was just one of
the developers I thought I should bring
this up and this is exactly what I said
I don't think we're actually dealing
with the problem we're having I think
we're dealing with us what I would call
a symptom of a problem and I had seen
enough of these iterations three
iterations that I could say this might
be a pattern so you hear this quote from
Einstein they attribute to Einstein does
anybody know the quote I'm referring to
doing the same thing over and over and
expecting a different outcome should be
the definition of insanity I don't know
if he actually said that but maybe he
did that's sort of what I saw here they
were expecting to learn something from
doing this over and over so I actually
told them this in a meeting after that
meeting nobody would talk to me
and that went on for several days and I
finally cornered somebody in a hallway a
young man
unfortunately for young people even
though they're faster and stronger than
us older people they get surprised so I
cornered him and he didn't know how to
get away I actually literally put my
arms out and I said Jim and he couldn't
turn away now he had to talk with me why
won't anybody talk with me and he said
the managers told us not to talk with
you
so this told me that yeah I actually hit
a nerve this was a bigger problem than
just us not being good at something I
won't go into the details anymore of
that but that led me to think I need to
give a name to this thing so this is
what I had noticed we would do something
we would end up with some problems we
would try to fix the problems we would
go further in doing that thing again and
this cycle would just continue and I
gave this a name and I think that this
is the same pattern I've seen now for
almost 20 years at many of the places
I've worked I call it the cycle of
continuous no improvements and this can
go on and on week after week or month
after month we do retrospectives we pick
things we want to get better at and we
never get better at them ok so I want to
move just a little further and I want to
go kind of quickly through the next set
of stuff but I want to wrap this up by
saying if if the estimates were off was
a symptom what was the actual problem
I'm not asking you to answer that but I
would like you to think about that and
have conversations about that this is
part of why I'm going out and doing
these talks is I want people to start
being willing to talk about these things
if the requirements weren't clear is
just a symptom and not the problem than
what's the actual problem in other words
if we define the requirements a lot
better up front and that still didn't
solve our problem then because it was
really about the understanding but what
is the problem the last one was they
kept changing if that's not the problem
keeping them from changing won't solve
it what might be the actual problem so
I'm not again I'm not asking you to
answer that right now
the
these are the kinds of things I think we
need to be talking about let's stop
looking at symptoms and calling them
problems let's gather up the symptoms
and see what problems they might be
actually the symptom of it's kind of
like if you get a if you have a food
allergy and you get a rash on your skin
and you put cream on the rash what are
we dealing with the symptom of the food
allergy that's kind of what I'm talking
about here so part third remember now we
only have eighty parts left after this
I'm going to talk about some questions
really quickly let me do this quickly
this is usually done for me as a seven
minute lightening talk but I want to
introduce it with this concept from
Peter block transformation comes more
from pursuing profound questions than
seeking practical answers this reminds
me of something my dad used to tell me
when I was a kid I heard him say this is
something like this several times he
said a really good question leads to a
better question not to an answer until
you finally get to a question that
resolves itself so you keep asking a
little bit better questions based on the
question you already have that can lead
you to a to the real thing you need to
be dealing with so I kind of like that
idea
so sometimes I will take a topic that
I'm interested in and I've noticed
seeing that everybody wants to get to
how do we solve this and I want to say
what's the right question to ask instead
of how do we solve it so I'll go through
a series of questions I'll make up as
many good questions I can I'll make up a
question and I'll reverse the question
I'll ask it from two different points of
view
I'll ask other people what would you
think about it I'm looking for that
better question and I think that's
served me pretty good so first of all I
like to imagine how wonderful things
could be even though I don't know if how
we would get there I just know that we
can always steer towards better if we
have a process that or a way of thinking
that allows us to do it and I like to
take pretty usually pretty small baby
steps it's not always the only way this
is really about the difference between
the things we think we want and the
really wonderful things that we could
have
if we allowed ourselves to have them but
there might be some problems that get in
our way so first of all we want control
uncertainty control and certainty may be
a problem when we ask to have control
uncertainty maybe there's something else
we should be talking about and that in
this case we're talking about we want
control of certainty of the time the
cost we didn't quite get schedules on
here but we would normally if we had a
hundred of these we would find something
like that there do you see where we're
at here we want certainty of these
things so to get that certainty we need
to make a bunch of guesses and we try to
do them as good as we can some people
comment if ik or educated or reason to
guess they're still just guesses so we
can do the planning that we need to do I
would ask this question can we improve
our chance at wonderful if we give up
this desire to have control uncertainty
it's worth pondering what does this have
to do with estimates so this is what I
like to think I I believe that there may
be whenever I see a symptom like this or
something that's showing itself to
potentially be a symptom I start
wondering is there a hidden problem and
I want to start investigating that and
asking those questions
I don't think of estimates as being the
problem I rarely see estimates
themselves as the problem I think that
they're a potential symptom if I start
investigating and I don't find a real
problem quickly then the estimates
probably aren't a problem our art aren't
a symptom of a problem they're just
there but I'm looking for what could be
wrong with it everybody does estimates
everywhere I've been and through many
many projects almost everybody does
estimates why do we do them well partly
because they seem like the right thing
to do how can something that seems so
right to so many people actually be
wrong but to me this is a great picture
my wife does all the pictures that I use
in my talks
she's a children's book illustrator and
author
she did this for another story you
probably recognize sort of the theme of
this one but I like this because this
nice attractive candy house it could be
a fun thing to go and enjoy an afternoon
there until you get too sick eating
candy I suppose but I like the smoke
that's coming out the chimney it's kind
of indicating there's something sinister
going on here so that's why I like to
use this in this slide often the things
that look the best are misguiding us we
have to be careful about that one
question I like to ask is how much work
did we have to do to get to the point
where we had sufficient information to
come up with what we might consider a
reasonable guess how much do we invest
in the first place how much did we
estimate that work I've actually had
people ask can you estimate how long it
would take to estimate this project have
you as anybody else ever had that
obviously there's at least 15 people
who've had that asked of them how do we
want to make a estimate about the
estimate about the estimate of how long
it will take us to do the work
how many estimates do we need before we
decide we'll even do the estimate that's
tricky this one I refer to earlier how
do we know we made a good decision one
that I often hear is we we use the
estimates to decide whether we should do
project day or project B if we decide to
do project 2a and we do it what have we
learned about project B along the way
nothing and if project a fails we're
really in a fix because we made a best
guess as to which projects we should do
and that we really didn't learn anything
should have we done the other one do we
know it was a good decision about the
priorities about how many people we
should hire whatever the decision
happens to be so I like to use this
little bit as sort of commentary from
Russell Acuff you should read some of
his things he's got stuff on YouTube as
well I believe he passed away a couple
decades or a decade or so ago managers
who don't know how to measure what they
want start wanting what they can measure
I don't think I have to even say
anything about that I've seen this I I
would guess most of you have seen this
because we can measure something that
starts becoming our goal there's another
famous quote I think
is a good heart slaw someone will have
to tell me as soon as you turn a measure
into a target it stops being a
reasonable measure these are troubling
things let's go on are these things we
think we want like those things we know
we can measure are they a trap is it
start us thinking that we need to get
those things and I'm gonna ask does it
make us become inflexible and this is
sort of the idea the sunk cost fallacy
we've already spent a hundred thousand
money units on this thing we don't want
to throw that away we should get it done
and then we spend another hundred
thousand and another hundred thousand of
course here a hundred thousand is like a
week's pay right I don't know but you
know what I'm saying right so whatever
you're using to judge we've already
spent a bunch of money that can force us
into thinking we need to keep down this
path that really isn't going to end well
for us but we don't yet know if it's
going to end well we need a better way
to think about things is it a hardening
agent what I've seen often is once
people make a decision they're reluctant
to unmake the decision and I think
that's something we need to really
consider we should make it easy to undo
decisions as soon as we have information
that shows us maybe we're going down the
wrong path so I'll give just one example
of a thing
it's on-time and on-budget a good
measure of success on a project I'm not
really going to ask you to say it out
loud but think about that for a moment
if you get the project done on time and
on budget what do we really know it
might be what we know is that we padded
it like you were saying here so much
that we couldn't get it wrong and once
we padded something that much we end up
using all the time we allocated for it
I've seen that also a lot of times
hopefully you haven't much but it's not
uncommon I'm going to share a couple of
the what I would call creative
accounting things I've seen we talked
about the padding of the estimates so if
we know we need to pad that why do we
need to pad the estimates anyway my shot
shout that out for me because they're an
echo and we know it something's going to
go wrong and it's probably based on
there are a bunch of unknowns that we
can't know right now
we're doing the estimates at the point
in the project we know the least amount
about it
so we're worried let's Pat it well
that's a creative that's not is that
really a helpful thing to do we're just
trying to manage some of these
expectations but I've seen this feature
cuts a feature cut is when we've done a
substantial amount of work on a project
and we have some features that we know
are we're not gonna able to deliver
because they're not getting through our
testing process and we literally cut cut
those features out that's to get us done
on time but if we're done on time but
and we cut features did we really get
done on time we got done by the deadline
but it wasn't for all the stuff we
thought we could get done another one
this is quite a bit more hideous and
that is that we are asked to not put our
time against the bookkeeping for this
project I will not ask for a show of
hands on that because that indicates
some really deep problems but in your
heart if you know you've been asked to
do this you might really Ronna delve
into what is the ramifications of this
similar thing to it is we are asked to
work a lot of hours near the end of the
project you get crunch time I will ask
that is anybody ever had crunch time we
had to work extra hours at the end of
the project way I'd say way over half of
you've raised your hands what this
basically means is the next project they
will say all that other project took six
weeks this next one's like that one it
will only take six weeks which implies
we're all gonna have to work a lot of
extra time near the end if it was really
that easily compared and it's not but
these kinds of creative estimating
mechanisms or I should say creative
accounting around it ruins our chance of
having good data if good data could help
us I'm gonna suspect good data wouldn't
so I would ask this question is getting
better at estimates actually going to
help if it's just a symptom it probably
won't it's getting better the only way
so I kind of like to do use this as a
kind of a bit of a joke but it's really
true for me you've heard the old idea of
garbage in garbage out with data if you
give garbage into your reporting system
your reports are gonna be worthless but
for me and junk food
I have weighed a lot more than I weigh
right now if I eat the junk food garbage
ghin garbage stays and then I have
problems losing that weight so can you
eat junk food in a better way do you
chew it more slowly do you chew it more
quickly do you only eat it at a certain
time of day that might help what things
can we do to make the junk food less of
a problem besides eating less of it or
none of it what could we do well I want
to suggest some of the possibilities but
yeah you can't eat junk food in a safe
way that will get rid of the problems of
the junk food okay so maybe there are
alternatives the alternative on the junk
food is one thing is don't eat the junk
food another one would be fill yourself
up on healthy food and if you still have
some room left well then you don't have
as much room for the junk food I don't
know you come up with your own ideas
this is a really question that I want to
ask if the kinds of decisions that we're
making require that we use estimates
maybe there are some other kinds of
decisions we should be making on our
projects
I've already seen for talks here today
at least well 3 talks in the part of
another one and I'm hearing a lot of
this over and over ideas about how can
we work in such a way that we can
deliver small batches really quickly and
learn from what we're doing that's
probably part of the theme of modern
software development there are are other
kinds of decisions but we're asking what
are those decisions what would they be
maybe there are better ways so we have
just enough time to cover a couple more
things I want to wrap this up by asking
first of all what should we be certain
about and I'll give you the answer of
what I think I think we should be
certain about that we have an
environment where people can excel in
their life and people can excel in their
work where it's easy for them to do the
best they can and they love doing it if
we create that environment we're gonna
get the best results this group of
people and this company is able to get
at the same time then we're gonna be
creating an environment where the great
solutions are inevitable based on that
earlier slide I want it to just be we
put everything in place so great things
will happen that's the way I like to
approach it
what must we control there's lots of
answers I can give for this but this is
the one that's worked best for me I
think let's control our urge to control
things I'll let that sink in for a
second but if we just quit worrying
about having that control that might be
the best thing to learn to control once
we've done that a lot of the pain of all
this other stuff can go away I'm gonna
share a little saying from be art
daybook sness does anybody know who that
is
did I say his name correctly so that
sound about right it's only one or two
of you know who it is so I think he's
right now the vice president of
performance at statoil
and he's written this book called beyond
implementing beyond budgeting but he's
got this little saying I really like the
fear of losing control is a big berry to
drink to change the fear is a barrier
but much of that control is just an
illusion of control and I would say in
most cases it is playing out an illusion
of control but the fear is real and
that's the problem we can't ignore that
that fear exists so we can't just rush
back to our company and say I heard this
guy talking about no estimates and I'd
like to do this and then when you get
there
you get fired for saying things like
that so I think that's kind of a warning
I know of two people who came back to me
after hearing one of my talks or having
me come and talk with their group about
it that they got laid off or fired
because they were trying to introduce
these kinds of ideas so I don't say rush
into it I say be cautious maybe
influence change so that at least in
your company you're allowed to talk
about is this thing working is that
thing working
what might we be able to do better
that's sort of where we're at so I think
that I'd like to how much time we have
left 10 10 minutes 15 minutes oh I
should slow down and talk much slower I
have two sections I still want to cover
I do have a lot more material than this
and I'm going to be here for the rest of
the conference if you want to talk about
this I'm up for that I want to just
share some ideas I've heard some from
other people most
these I've heard at conferences or on
videos of toxic conferences Mary
poppendieck who's probably spoken at
this conference I don't know said this
at the keynote at the agile XP I mean
the XP 2016 last year I like this really
successful digital organizations do not
estimate estimates are for cost centers
not for products a cost Center is a
place in a company or a department in a
company where it doesn't directly
generate income they're there to manage
something like the facilities and their
job is to make sure everybody's got a
desk that will lead to us being able to
work but it doesn't actually generate
income for the company so what are
estimates good for she is saying the
estimates are good for the cost centers
that makes sense there Kent Beck who
hopefully all got some of these books
Kent Beck has just got he's just full of
wonderful ideas and he shares them all
the time I love this one an alternative
to estimates to the most important thing
until either it ships or it's no longer
the most important thing that's a simple
rule it's easy to try and you would know
pretty quickly if it's working for you
or not that's that's worth experimenting
with I like this one from Martin Fowler
now again I'm showing these slides I
want to tell you I don't know whether
they agree with me on anything I'm not
trying to say this is proof of what I'm
doing I'm just sharing some other things
I've seen Martin says this his team's
progress at first they struggle with
estimating and then they get pretty good
at it and eventually they get to the
point where they don't need it or often
don't need it I'd like to start at the
we often don't need it part and not
worry about the trying to get better at
them
I think he's implying here and I could
be wrong that we still need to go
through this process of getting to where
we don't need them anymore I like what
this Michelle McCarthy says she has a
radio or a podcast kind of a show with
her husband Jim one of the problems with
the schedule is that it gives us the
idea that we can take that long so
whenever we make a schedule we're
tricking ourselves I think it's what
there was a law of that as well is it
Parkinson's law or something like that
you know work will will grow to fill the
time we've allocated for it once we make
that schedule well you know we're gonna
get waste into that schedule
we put things off until last minute all
sorts of things another really great I
love Ron Jeffries and I really enjoyed
this book he came out with recently
nature of software development
estimating when will be done is wrong
forcing the answer is worse and I think
that that's sort of what you brought up
we do the estimates because we're told
we need to do the estimates I've heard
Bob Martin speak on estimates several
times he has a talk on doing estimates
and you can get a video of it from some
of the conference's he's been at he's
also got a video on his website where
you the clean coder website where you
can buy the video they're really
entertaining but he basically said this
the only honest estimate is I don't know
now he still advocates for estimates I
don't have a problem with that but if we
really understand at the end of s any
estimate we have to remind our boss or
the person who's asked for it or whoever
thinks they need the estimate to still
say here's my estimate but really I
don't know so after a while there get
kind of where they go maybe we shouldn't
ask that guy for estimates anymore I
don't know but this is sort of I think
what he's suggesting he also said I I
quoted him from a talk most estimates
are lies so he's trying to get us to
where we're doing at least honest
estimates so I'll share a couple more
Joshua karaeski I worked with him for a
bit in industrial logic he's a wonderful
guy he's experimented he says in 2007
with what can we do instead of estimates
especially the 'story point estimates
and velocity and they dropped using them
and when I worked with him for six
months I was with his company we didn't
do any estimates at all we were
programming almost every day remotely
doing some mob programming I never heard
anyone ask for an estimate or I never
heard anyone giving an estimate I show
Fred Brooks you know who fred brooks is
he wrote the mythical man-month he's got
this set of essays just because he's so
friendly and it makes me by association
look like I'm a good guy so I like this
I don't know if he's ever said anything
about estimates that really plays into
my thinking but I like this one it is
very difficult to make a vigorous
plausible job risking defense of an
estimate that is derived by no
quantitative method supported by little
data and so
chiefly by the hunches of managers now
I'm not sure if that really is alignment
with what I'm talking about but I like
this I like the way he talks I'm gonna
share a couple slides from people who
have also been talking about this Vasco
2 already wrote a book I think you can
get this book rather economically online
this is something that he says basically
what he's saying here is that we make
estimates about a system we know nothing
about we think that we have something we
can make predictions on but we haven't
anything to observe yet I like that Neil
Killick was one of the original people
also talking about no estimates starting
in 2012 and I like this little one that
he says here there are ways to deliver
software with no estimates and people
are figuring out how to do this if
something says you can't do this
I disagree I've been working this way
for almost 10 years starting 2009 I have
not done an estimate for software
development and I've worked on dozens if
not a hundred projects in that time
interesting to me that people say you
can't do this
double poncho who is Givens three or
four great talks you can find online
he's got a lot too good to say about
biases and and our assumptions and the
ideas that we just do things and we
don't realize what's influencing us to
do them so it's worth looking up some of
the stuff he's done estimates predispose
us to a solution I've talked about that
already as we went but what this means
to me is once we've kind of made the
estimate we probably are going to stick
with that path until maybe it's too late
for us Alan's here he's given another
talk he also talks he has a great video
on no estimates well worth the hour it
would take to watch it easy to find in
YouTube he says why do we estimate
anyway it's just a habit a ritual we do
it even when we can't come up with an
actual reason you came up with some
reasons but I've been to a lot of places
where you just do your estimates and you
just can't question it so we're getting
near the being done I think that I want
to quickly run through this next little
part this is how I've actually worked
with
estimates and they do it probably faster
than I should but I think I can do it in
five minutes is that about right five
minutes so often they want people ask
can you ask you know do you have any
questions near the end of something like
this I don't think that's reasonable for
us to do here so I'll be here the rest
of the conference just come and ask me
questions and we can talk we don't need
to do it like this I'm just the same as
the rest of you just closer to the end
of my life okay so the value of
another's experience it's not to tell us
whether or how we should do something
it's to give us some kind of hope that
we can also improve our our environment
where we're working this is what I'm
about so I'm going to tell you a lot of
times a product expert a product - owner
whatever brings you a project as if it's
this work of art everything's neat
everything's in its place
it's really clean they want to bring to
you put it on your desk - say that's the
project we want it's all defined see you
later
they think they've defined the project
but this is full of those symptoms that
we were talking about I think a project
looks a little more like this there's a
different work of art this indicates to
me there's all kinds of stuff we're
thinking about and put a lot of stuff we
don't even recognize yet and I think
it's even worse then around the edges
it's cloudy and when we get near the
edge we go oh man there's a whole bunch
of this over there and down below and up
above and we're surrounded by all these
things we can never know if up front so
this is what I believe it's in the doing
of the work that we can discover the
work that we must do we have to start
doing stuff so we can expose reality
let's find something to work on and try
to deliver that we won't do this as an
exercise but this is what I'm going to
cover for just a second often what ends
up happening is we do estimates so we
can have the conversation about how long
something like take and we want to learn
more about it but what's important is
the criteria on which we base those
estimates let's see what that is for me
I'm not looking for size or smallness
I'm looking at for something I can work
on and I put it this way it has to have
some kind of potential value it has to
be recognizable I mean
like in that Jackson Pollock painting I
could see the different orange spots
orange this is kind of anything those
things might be cohesive maybe those
things should be brought together let's
look at what that was it needs to be
understandable once we get something I
want to be able to understand it if this
is all the requirements on this project
I can't understand this whole project
but I can understand some small part of
it if I take that small part I have
something I maybe can get a chance to
understand if it's potentially valuable
let's just say I recognize that part as
being potentially valuable and I'm
talking with my customer so yeah that
would be valuable for us to have I can
figure out what's cohesive what belongs
together and what doesn't and figure out
which one of these do we want to work on
first and now I've gotten something
quite a bit smaller and I did no
estimates this is clearly smaller than
what this was originally and each one of
these bits is smaller this is now
smaller because we've taken out
something to work on I want it to be
distinct that to me means that it's very
clearly a chunk this is something that's
distinct that I could decouple from the
rest and I want it to be cohesive this
stuff actually belongs together if we
can have five drop-down boxes but two of
them can be done as a pair and the other
three could be done separately let's do
the two first what we've done is we've
got some weakened Aldi couple work on
deliver into use and determine what do
we learn from this what I like to see is
that this requires no estimates and when
I find those qualities I have something
I can work on and this gives us another
cycle that cycle is we do a little of
this we do the work on it so we can
learn something from it and on we go
over and over we're delivering from day
one I've worked on many projects now
where we started delivering something of
value in the first day or two and we
just kept adding bits to it I'm not
going to give this example because we've
run out of time but in this example what
I talked about is how we discovered that
there were some things that were more
obviously important to the customer than
others let's start on those and if 80%
of the features give us our 20% of
features give us most of what we want
the 80% of what we want let's go for
those
we can't find those automatically we
have to do some work of actually
delivering and seeing if it's delivering
value once we found one of those things
we think has value I want to do as
little as it is possible when we do as
little of it as possible I'm looking for
the 20% of that feature that will give
most of the reason we wanted that
feature when we do this I call it 80/20
80/20 it basically means we can do as
little as 4% of this project and deliver
most of what the customer wanted and
I've seen this in action many times now
I call this deliver features until board
because once you start doing this the
customer starts realizing they didn't
want the rest of that they got the big
things that there was important to them
done so let's end this up if we could
crank up our ability to do that let's do
that and see how that works for us
that's basically this pattern that we
have an idea we act on it we deliver
something we've learned something and
we'd go on and at every step we will
learn things we can always go to a story
stage and say nah this isn't good let's
go back to another idea or get to the
designing code and say this isn't too
bad but we want to change some things we
have to be open to that now you hear me
talking about the symptoms that we saw
earlier and what was really the
underneath problem for example change
will happen we don't get to say stop the
changes because it's just gonna happen
and of course this is what agile is
about we just do that over and over and
over and over now we should be done
right now so I'm gonna go this is the
last slide I've been doing this for
eight plus years and it's worked for me
over and over again and for about the
eight years before it I was
experimenting with it in different
environments and was able to use it
occasionally once a year I'd get some
kind of project where I could do that so
the most important slide of the whole
pack don't forget to vote green when you
leave you put the green card in the
thing and I'm gonna be here all day and
the rest of the week I'm happy to talk
with you so thank you very much
thanks for coming to the top
[Applause]